lawmakers on both sides of the aisle
again a briefing with border patrol
chief raul ortiz on the heels of this
heated confrontation with a group of
agents in texas watch
i do think that uh morales
i do think if we're losing way too many
asians we continue to do the job and the
mission
that we signed up for it's kind of hard
to say that for evil the triumph is for
doing that to do nothing that's exactly
what's happening there good men are
doing nothing you're allowing the legal
agency
florida congressman carlos jimenez met
with ortiz yesterday and congressman
what was his message what'd you get out
of that meeting
no he admitted that the the morale of
the
you know of customs and border
protection agents is at an all-time low
he also you know we asked him how many
how many encounters they've had i mean
the first quarter of this year they had
over 650 000 encounters that means that
if you took that on a yearly basis
that's over 2.6 million encounters we
asked them how many were not encountered
how many people just slipped by the
border he uh he took a he took a a guess
thing uh close to 800 000 probably you
know come through undetected so we're
talking about over three million uh
immigrants are crossing the border and
so yeah it's uh it's a difficult
situation um you know he was frank but
uh look he has to toe the line he he
does have a boss and his boss expects
him to say certain things and not say
other things and so it was quite
eye-opening and and i i appreciate his
frankness but i also understand the
difficult position he's in you mentioned
frankness was there transparency did the
administration through raul ortiz
promise any more transparency especially
in light of those secret migrant flights
that we've been showing for the last
week
no he didn't he also admitted that there
are differences in policies in the
northern border in the southern border
he asked for more more
technology to help him more people to
help him but he didn't ask for a wall
and yet i know that when i went to uh to
the border back in march the customs and
border protection agents on the ground
wanted that that wall built they will
not build that wall because that wall
will be a symbol of what can be
and this entire crisis is is one of
president biden's making major is making
their policies are causing this wild
influx and and rush
to the border and it's overwhelming our
agents and that's the reason why their
morale is so low congressman do you
think he is satisfied with the way the
divided administration has made
decisions with this
look i'm not getting getting to his head
obviously you know he's the the chief if
i were the chief i certainly wouldn't be
be satisfied i know what was working
before and all of a sudden you come in
on january 20th you know of 2021 you
change the world and then all of a
sudden you have this this wild influx
this massive influx of immigrants and
they're basically overrunning your your
agency you know that's not a a recipe
for success and i'm sure that uh you
know he'd like to see things change but
he really can't say that because he
works for the president and the
secretary when covet officially becomes
endemic did he say anything about
remaining mexico
well yeah because he's actually afraid
that that title 42 will be eliminated
because that's one of the tools that
used to to uh to deport uh whoever it is
they're deporting you know he also
didn't tell us i asked him specifically
how many of the over two million you
know immigrants that you've encountered
uh have are still in the united states
he didn't give me a good answer on that
so
i would expect that the vast majority of
those two million are somewhere in the
united states some of them are being you
know taken back to mexico using title 42
both in mexico and the northern border
with canada but uh you know the change
in policy is really what's causing this
morale you know to be so low and uh and
customs and border protection you know
we had this uh this this under control
under the trump administration
it's just a hardheadedness and i don't
know i don't i really you can't be this
dumb okay i mean you just can't be this
stupid uh to to change all these
policies and then they will never go
back to the policies that work because
then they'd have to admit you know what
president trump was right and all along
we need to go back to those policies it
has to be purposeful congressman i agree
it has to be and we only have a little
less than a minute here but um ron
desantis he was talking about the border
issues and he wants him to stay out of
florida i'm just going to read this for
you it says we don't want the problems
from the southern border to be imported
into the state of florida so the people
that are instrumental in that we want to
hold accountable we're not going to let
the binding administration's
recklessness at the border impose cost
of the state of florida so is this the
new normal to where the local and state
officials have to pick up the pieces
from what the feds aren't doing uh 30
seconds or so less
oh yeah sure yeah yeah they're being
look all these migrants are being
transported all around the nation and
all these migrants are going to need
services etc that cost money and so
yeah a lot of them are ending up in in
florida without a doubt and
and the governor is is right you know
why should the people of florida the
good people of florida have to pay for
the failings of the biden administration
so i hope you know that the governor and
i know the governor will will try to
hold president biden and the
administration uh liable for for all the
expenses and the hardship that's being
caused to the state of florida it's like
we had a reporter in the room
congressman carlos manez we appreciate
your time and insight this morning thank
you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now